The general good experience and so yeah,
so finally in all this time,
you know Dana and the UFC is saying we want ben to asking me about benioff
skirt.
I'm ranked number seven in the world or you know,
somewhere around there,
12 and l.
and so I remember I was going to the Asian food store cause I was gonna make
some tom cost soup and bjorn calls me and said,
you're released full,
full,
you're released.
You can go.
And I say,
I appreciate that.
So Friday morning,
it's Thursday night,
Friday morning,
it's in November,
sometime in May,
mid November morning they fax over the release my management,
fax it to UFC headquarters and all of a sudden that afternoon there's a,
you know,
like little scrum wherever was asking Dana questions and the data says we're not
interested in Ben.
And I said,
wait,
what just happened there?
Right?
Because for the last three months they were saying we were interested in wearing
short words twisted.
Now I finally produced this full release for Bella tour that I got and now
they're not interested.
And so I said,
wow,
I just got caught in the middle of this and uh,
was there a reason given well,
so.
Okay,
so the Monday.
So then I say F that I buy my,
I bought a plane ticket to Vegas for Monday,
so that was Friday.
That happens.
I say,
fuck that.
I'm going to Vegas,
I'm not taking this shit,
you know.
So a Monday I buy my plane ticket to Vegas,
I fly out to Vegas.
Do you have to headquarters a lot?
I met with Lorenzo.
Dana was on the little speakerphone dealy and they offered me a contract,
but it would be confidential and I would have to fight one fight for the world
series of fighting,
which is like,
well that's bizarre.
What?
Yeah.
At the same fight for the world series a funding relationship with the world
series,
like a feeder organization at that time.
Something.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
yeah,
Morrowind,
Mariah's just engage you.
Both those kids came from champs over there.
I think the relationship is very hazy between the old world series of fighting
in the UFC because there was also people don't want the other way.
Right.
Andre Arlovski gets dropped from the FC,
goes to world series.
Anthony Johnson,
boom.
All these people.
So they say one fight,
one fight,
world series of fighting.
We will pay Zoopla.
We'll pay you.
Would you do one fight?
Okay.
I say let that's eft up,
but okay.
I said,
I don't think anyone's going to go for it,
but I'll do it.
So I leave.
And uh,
about six hours later I got a phone call and says,
that deal is no longer available.
We're not going to make you an offer.
Yeah.
So wow.
And you have no idea why?
Well,
I,
so here's my guess.
I've never got to sit face to face meeting and say,
what was your problem with me?
I think there's four things.
My mind,
number one,
he didn't really like me.
I'm stemming from the.
I called them out on the steroid thing,
you know,
where he said it's impossible and this is where our disagree.
It's impossible to test all UFC athletes.
I said,
let's not true.
You sat does it all over the world for all kinds of athletes.
Right.
You can do it.
It's just expensive,
but let's just call it.
What is.
You're a private business.
You don't have to do drug testing.
It's basically they do it now.
Do it now.
Do it through Usada.
So you're totally right.
Yeah.
So I was correct and now.
But that was,
you know,
when Dana is wrong in an argument,
but he's got this huge army that follows him and he said I'd rather hit.
I think his quote was Bev,
I'd rather watch [inaudible] fucking bad ass him fight,
you know,
I think he said something like,
ambien takes.
Ben Asked her if it goes asleep.
Yeah,
there,
there was a few of them.
So the personal attacks started.
Right?
So that,
that's number one.
But uh,
you know,
it's that thing,
you're,
you're experiencing this thing that she can't do.
She's the wife is not a comedian.
It's another thing.
I think comics also have a bond that that I feel like the outside person can
never totally understand as well.
Just the way we joke around with each other,
like if just the things you and I have said to each other,
if we said these things in an office like Holy Shit,
lost human resources would both go to jail.
I think you'd go to jail more than me.
I am the worse,
but thank God that NBC last it,
those friends writers made a lot of progress for us because.
Okay,
so there was this famous lawsuit on friends.
The writer's assistant sued the writers in the writer's room because they were
saying something about the actresses are saying like fucking them with twigs or
something crazy and they sued.
The writer's assistant sued the writers for sexual harassment and said,
I have to hear all this disgusting Shit.
And the writers one,
because they said it was part of our creative process.
Well it is.
It certainly is.
And especially with Comedians,
we have said ridiculous shit to each other.
Yeah,
I mean like we,
we just like guys.
First of all,
I Talon Adelia me,
we will said ridiculous shit like about each other.
Like say like,
how loud fuck you.
Fuck you bro.
First of all my top favorites.
Me,
I'm a top.
You're just going to give in.
You're just going to give in,
you know,
spinning your hand and rubbing on your butt.
And we will do that to each other because it's how we make each other laugh that
we need something really extreme.
You wanna you want to be for the fight came like they do on the use of drug
testing a roses,
walking back through the hallway with her official as she crossed paths with
you,
Ana and all by herself.
And you wanna go ahead.
Oh yeah.
She like in a different tone of voice to like the weirdest,
like she didn't seem like herself or something.
I mean I'm sure she's getting in fight mode or whatever and it's just like
breaking in or close.
And she's like,
and that gave her like the so you know,
and she gave me the what's up and then she was like,
I'm just like,
I think she asked me something like,
as you buy the ticket or I was like,
just like,
you believe them or do you believe in them or something like that.
Do you believe him?
Did you buy the ticket?
And then she walked off
and did say no.
And I was just like,
it was like,
did you buy the test?
She's keyser soze.
I didn't do that like all week long.
Like even in a little way in,
you know,
after the way as a sort of like all kinds of stuff.
We were fucking shit man.
Rose
came back to the locker room.
Now we're ready all week.
We've been deflecting shit.
And I rose is a very emotional person in temporary.
Like she's,
we got to keep rolling,
keep rolling straight because she comes in with the wrong look on her face.
I'll,
something's wrong.
She goes off and does the drug test and comes back.
And when she sat down,
she says,
we have to,
we have to have a meeting now that's cold.
We have to have a meeting is called for shutting down.
Everybody get the fuck out.
We were bouncing.
We have to have a meeting is like kind of another way of saying start to count
down with leaving.
We have to have a meeting.
And when she said that,
the way she said it,
I meant everything came over me like,
Oh fuck,
what happened?
And then when she said,
would you want to sit in the back?
What do you want to told to,
do you believe him?
Did you buy the ticket?
And then left without any explanation.
Yo.
When Roe,
when Roe said that to me,
my fucking head exploded it.
And the only thing I can say,
Oh shit,
I don't want to have to fucking think about this all night.
Oh,
why did you stop being religious?
Uh,
I started in high school and stopped in graduate school.
So when you started being religious in high school,
so it wasn't something that your family introduce you to.
My parents were pretty secular.
They,
they weren't antireligious it,
what,
that wasn't a thing then,
but this is 1971 when I was in high school and the,
in the sort of Nissan born again,
movement was starting and there was no religious affiliation.
It was just like,
it's me and Jesus.
That's it.
It's just you and the Lord.
There's a lot of these um,
very charismatic hip,
young preachers that are doing sort of a thing like that where they don't even
have their own church to like rent time in the church and they have these
meetings where it's not,
it's just nondenominational and they just talk about God and yet they get a lot
of people fired up.
Yup.
And uh,
you know,
the place I went to this place called the barn in Locker Santa where I grew up
in,
you know,
they played guitar and
sang to a sex cult.
It was kind of one starts banging people.
I was hoping for something like that,
but no,
no,
that,
that is one of the problems with the utopia,
the 19th century utopian experiments,
they always turned into this free sex for the leader.
Well,
it always seems like whenever there's a man that's in a position where people
start worshiping him,
right,
you know,
and then they start hanging on his every word.
He's like,
I started going to start fucking some of these people.
Well,
I do.
I covered Jim Jones and uh,
you know,
the way I phrase it is that no one joins a cult.
They join a group that they think is going to do good,
save the world.
Kind of helped me improve my life,
improve the lives of others.
And there's pictures online.
You can see if Jim Jones with Jerry Brown,
governor Jerry Brown in his first round and you know,
they were man in the soup kitchens.
He was very liberal,
open to African Americans being part of the church in San Francisco.
They're gays women.
Uh,
you know,
it was a really cutting edge,
pioneering thing.
And at the time it seemed like,
yeah,
that,
that's a cool thing.
I'm going to join this group,
not me,
but you know,
the people that did this in the fifties and sixties when he was coming up and
then into the seventies and then,
then,
yeah,
he started having sex and drugs and then the,
you know,
the feds started kind of poking around and taxes and that's when they went to
South America speaking,
which I think this week is the spike specialists now,
the paramount network on Waco and waco going on,
like right now.
I think it's like a started Sunday.
Yeah.
I think it's a six part series or something along those lines.
See,
that's an interesting one.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm absolutely convinced most of these guys believe what they say now.
Maybe,
maybe they're bullshitters at the start or they only partially believe,
but they,
they repeat their rhetoric,
their followers give them positive reinforcement.
They come to believe it.
And uh,
you know,
David Koresh,
he was right down the barrel.
He choked,
totally believed,
willing to die for his beliefs.
And he also was having sex with everybody.
Yes.